THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE. WE
WELCOME ALL MEMBERS IN THE
PUBLIC BACK TO THE FIRST
HEARING OF THE YEAR. IT'S GOOD
TO BE ABLE TO SEE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WE'D LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE CARE SOME
HOUSEKEEPING BEFORE WE GET INTO
THE MEAT OF TODAY'S HEARING. WE
HAVE A NEW COMMITTEE
COMPOSITION HERE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE WANT TO WELCOME
THE NEW VICE CHAIRPERSON OF THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE THAT'S SENATOR
NIELSEN WE WELCOME OUR NEW VICE
CHAIR IN THINKING FOR SERVICE
WELL HE MAY BE NEW TO THE VICE
CHAIR ROLE HE IS NOT NEW TO THE
COMMITTEE AND WE'RE- GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THIS WORK. WE WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR CHAIR EMERITUS
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG WHO
WEEK RETURNING IN HIS ROLE HERE
TO THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE SENATOR
WIENER IS WELL WE WELCOME BACK
TO THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE AND OF COURSE
I KNEW TO OUR COMMITTEE BUT NOT
NEW TO THE SENATE WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR WORKING WELCOME.
SENATOR DURONTO RIGHT TO THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE AS WE DO AT THE START
OF EVERY TWO YEAR SESSION WE
WILL BE ADOPTING OUR COMMITTEE
RULES AND THAT WE ALSO WILL BE
A LACK TEAM A NEW COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT. IT'S ALL OF OUR
GUESTS WERE VERY GRATEFUL THAT
MISS VARGAS WILL BE JOINING THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE TEAM
HERE- HER FIRST OFFICIAL DAY
WAS THIS PAST MONDAY- IAN AND-
WERE SO APPRECIATIVE THAT SHE
CAN BE TAKEN OVER FOR THE
LEGENDARY MISS LANCHESTER- WE
HAVE ONE BILL IN ADDITION TO.
THAT THE RULES THAT WILL BE
ADOPTING TODAY IN ELECTING MS
VARGAS AS THE COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT WE HAVE ONE URGENCY
BILL IT'S GOING TO BE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY LET'S FOCUS ON
PROPOSITION NINETEEN CLEAN UP.
AND BEFORE WE GET INTO ADOPTING
A QUORUM WE WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
TAKE CARE OF SOME HOUSEKEEPING
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN OF
COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATURA
SAYS WELL AS- THE AND CREDIBLE.
TEAM EMPLOYEE TEAM FROM THE
SENATE IT WE MUST NANI'S GAS.
SAYING AD HERE TO SEE. D FACE
COVERING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE OR TO SAY HAS MADE NEXT
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THE PUBLIC
CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PRACTICE AT
PROCESS. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. IN ADDITION WE WILL BE
USING OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. VIA
TELEPHONE WE WELCOME ANY AND
ALL TESTIMONY VIA TELEPHONE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BETTER
PARTICIPATE VIA TELEPHONE
TODAY. PLEASE CALL INTO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE WELCOME
YOU AT EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX FOUR
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE AN ACCESS
CODE OF EIGHT SEVEN SIX. EIGHT
NINE FOUR ONE THE PHONE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS ON YOUR
SCREEN NOW IT'S ALSO ON THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE. WEBSITE IF YOU NEED
ANY INSTRUCTIONS IS WELL. WHEN
WE MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'RE GONNA BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE. THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME IN
WAIT PIECING IMPATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR. TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. FINALLY LACING
GENTLEMEN WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
ANY CHALLENGES BUT- ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
AT ANY TIME DURING THE HEARING.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OUR
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. OR HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED AGAIN
WE WELCOME ANY AND ALL COMMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY. AT MY
PROMISES THIS WE'RE GOING TO GO
SLOW WE'RE GONNA MAKE SURE ALL
INVOLVED ARE ON THE SAME PAGE.
AND OF COURSE PATIENTS GOES A
LONG WAY HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO THE CHIEF
CONSULTANT. ALSO ACTING AS THE
COMMITTEE SYSTEM TODAY THAT'S
CALLING- NOW WE WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MR NOW FOR ALL OF
HIS HARD WORK. MR CANAL IF YOU
COULD PLEASE. WHAT YOU'RE
QUORUM. THANK YOU SENATOR SAID
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE PRESIDENT
NIELSEN SENATOR NIELSEN SAID
DRAWS SEND DRAWS- PRESS SENATOR
HURTS HE SENATE HERTZBERG
PRESIDENT SENATOR WIENER
PRESENT. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN
ALL FIVE IT ARE PRESENT HERE IN
THE MEETING ROOM WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE MOVING ON TO OUR
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS THIS IS
THE ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
RULES AS WELL AS SELECTING OUR
NEW COMMITTEE ASSISTANT IT'S
OLD VARGAS. IS THERE A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG IN A SECOND. IN A
SECOND BY CENTER DRIVE SO EVEN
MOTION ON A SECOND ON THE FLOOR
TO BE ABLE TO ADOPT THE
COMMITTEE RULES AS WELL AS
SELECT IT'S A VARGAS IS A NEW
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT. MISTER
ALLEGRI NOW PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE
HI SENATOR NIELSEN ALL RIGHT
NIELSEN HI SENATOR DORADO.
DORADO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG BY
BERG BY SENATOR WIENER ALL
RIGHT SENATOR WIENER HI. FIVE
ZERO. WITH A FIVE ZERO AT THE
RULE HAVE BEEN A- IN ITS OF OUR
IS NOW FISH. THE NEW COMMITTEE
ASSISTANT FOR THE GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE HAVE LINED BILL ON
ORDER HERE TODAY THIS IS SB
FIVE THIRTY NINE AGAIN THIS IS
CRITICAL PROP NINETEEN CLEAN
UP. I'M GONNA TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HER MAJORITY LEADER
WHO. WE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ABLE TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
ASSESSOR'S REMOTELY VIA ZOOM A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO AND IN THE
MAJORITY LEADER HAS TAKEN UPON
HIMSELF TO BE ABLE TO. OFFER UP
THESE CRITICAL CLEAN UP ITEMS
FOR POP NINETEEN. MR MAJORITY
LEADER THE FLOOR IS YOURS ON
SENATE BILL FIVE THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS. ARM
V. EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA VOTED IN THIS LAST
NOVEMBER ELECTIONS. FOR
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. THAT MADE
CERTAIN CHANGES TO PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN BASICALLY. IT ALLOWED
TAXPAYERS MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
TRANSFER THEIR CURRENT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN BASIS IN
THEIR HOMES. BASICALLY ALTHOUGH
WE'VE HAD SOME DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS LEAGUE SOME ISSUES OVER
THE OVER THE YEARS ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES OF SOMEONE'S IN
ONE COUNTY WANTS TO MOVE TO
ANOTHER. THEY CAN KEEP THEIR
PROP THIRTEEN BASIS. AND THE
COUNTY THAT THEY LEAVE WILL OF
COURSE INCREASE DRAMATICALLY
ASSUMING THE VALUE OF THE
PROPERTIES HIGHER. THERE THE
THEIR PORTION OF THE OF TAXES
ON THAT. AND SECONDLY GENERATED
NEED REVENUE FOR FIRE
PROTECTION AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE- THERE. WE'RE CERTAIN
DISCUSSIONS YOU CORRECTLY
ALLUDED TO MR CHAIRMAN WITH THE
ASSESSORS AND OTHERS AS TO
CERTAIN IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE
WE DID NOT DRAFT THE STATUTORY
LANGUAGE TO ACCOMPANY THE
CONSTITUTIONAL LANGUAGE. IS THE
MEMBERS KNOW THIS MEASURE GOT
ON THE BALLOT. THROUGH A- SUPER
MAJORITY OF BOTH HOUSES AND ON
TO THE BALLOT AND VOTED BY THE
PEOPLE. AND SO- THERE SOME
CLEAN UP LANGUAGE SHOULD AS IT
RELATES TO EMERGENCY AUTHORITY
OF THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
SOME OTHER DEFINITIONAL
LANGUAGE TO BE HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THE PEOPLE OF QUESTIONS. THAT
THAT THERE CERTAINLY NEEDED HAS
TO THE IMPLEMENTATION IF YOU
KNOW AFTER PROP THIRTEEN WE HAD
AB EIGHT THAT THEN WAS
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE OFTEN
WHAT OCCURS WITH RESPECT TO
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS. IS
THAT THEIR STATUTORY
IMPLEMENTATION LANGUAGE THAT'S
CONSISTENT WITH. STATUTORY
AUTHORITY BUT DOZEN OVERSTEPPED
THE CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY
THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE GIVEN BY
VIRTUE OF SPEAKING WITH RESPECT
TO THIS MATTER. AND SO WE HAVE
IS WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE ERNIE DRONE
BURKE OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY
ASSESSOR AND PRESIDENT. OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS VANESSA
SHOP IS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SHARING. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
MAJORITY LEADER LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
BE HEARING FROM THOSE WHO ARE
IN SUPPORT AS THE MAJORITY
LEADER SAID WE'VE TO LEAD
WITNESSES WERE AN ASSET EACH
LEAD WITNESS PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES. WILL
THEN GO I SEEN FOR ASKING
ANYONE ELSE FOR SUPPORT IN WILL
GO TO OUR OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT.
LET'S CHECK IN. IT LOOKS LIKE
WE MAY HAVE SOME TECHNICAL.
CHALLENGES WITH THE PHONE LINE
IT WITH HER- BUT THEY'RE TO
WITNESSES THE LADIES IN GERMAN
WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
FIRST AND FOREMOST. IT IS THAT
WE'RE. GONNA A SEE IF WE- HAVE
ANY. LOOK AT THE PATTY HERE.
GIVE US ONE MOMENT MEMBERS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
AGAIN
THANK YOU SO MUCH RAISING JENNA
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE WE PAGE
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE OF
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE LINE TO
LAYS IN GERMAN WHAT WE'RE GONNA
DO IS WE'RE GONNA TAKE OUR
SUPPORT TESTIMONY FIRST I'M
GONNA LOOK TO IN PERSON
TESTIMONY THEN WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO THE PHONE LINES TO BE TO
CHECK IN WITH. THAT TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE THEN
WILLGO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE THE LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THAT STARTED HERE IN THE
GALLERY TO SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE WISHING TO OFFER SUPPORT
SEEN IN HEARING KNOWING OFFER
SUPPORT HERE IN THE GALLERY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. ANYONE IN
REMOTE ROOM ONE TWELVE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
HEARING SEEN NO ONE THAT LAYS
IN GENERAL WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR MODERATOR NOT A
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE WAITING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB. FIVE THIRTY
NINE IF YOU COULD PLEASE K.
WHAT NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE.
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
WE HAVE LINE NUMBER TWENTY THAT
POINT TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S KRISTY ABOUT MINE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH IS FAMILY PROCEED
YOUR CALL- MADAME MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN JUST GIVE US THE NUMBER
FOLKS WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE AND
THEN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER MADAME MODERATOR. WE
HAVE. THREE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE.
GO TO OUR NEXT COMMENT ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM LINE NUMBER
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- JEFF NEAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES HAPPY TO ADD OTHER
SUPPORT FOR THIS MEASURE AND
THANKS TO THE AUTHOR AND THE-
OTHER GOOD PEOPLE WORKING ON
THIS BILL FOR REACHING OUT IN A
COLLABORATIVE PROCESS. THANK
YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PHONE CALL NOT A MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE FOURTEENTH IF I HAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN THE CHOIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE I'M LINDA FLEMING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR STATE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION THE STATE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION ALONG WITH THE
FIFTEEN COUNTY ASSESSOR'S
SUPPORT SENATE BILL FIVE THREE
NINE THE BILL IS COURT
CONSTITUTIONAL AND STATUTORY
DUTIES ARE TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
OF THE ADMINISTRATION OF
PROPERTY TAXES IN CALIFORNIA.
AT A FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH
BOARD MEETING THE BOARD
UNANIMOUSLY VOTED TO SUPPORT
SENATE BILL. FIVE THIRTY NINE
TO IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS OF
PROPOSITION NINETEEN. MHM GET
ON BEHALF OF THE FOR THE
LETTERS. TO TOO MANY. POSITION
I. NUMBER CHANGE THE PART TAX
WILL. WHEN PROPERTY BETWEEN A
PARENT AND CHILD. AND GRANT
WILL GROW. AND WHEN FOR
INNOVATION VALUE WHICH- THE
SAME PERSON AND VICTIMS OF WILD
AND ARE GAS. SPECIFICALLY
SENATE BILL THIRTY NINE
PROVIDES TO CLARIFY FROM CHASE
LANGUAGE THE BILL FOR BY
DEFINITE. SIX FOR A- AN
IMPORTANT IT GIVES THE BOARD
BECAUSE THEY EXPRESS ABILITY
PROPAGATE. REGULATION TO A
SYSTEM IMPLEMENTING. NINETEEN
IN A MANNER. AGAIN THE HE
SUPPORTS IN ABOUT. ON THREE
YOUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE THE COME.
BY CHANCE IS A ACTIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH A MATTER. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
AND GIVE OUR YOUR MEMBERS
THAT'S GO TO OUR CALL IN.
MATTER MODERATE. THANK YOU LINE
TWELVE WEEKS AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS FROM SIEGEL CAL
HARDER FEDERATION WE'RE NOT THE
ONLY A TO FIVE R. S. FIVE
THIRTY NINE TODAY AN
ARTIFICIALLY SUPPORTED AMENDED
BECAUSE WHILE THE LEGISLATION
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IS THE RESULT IN THE
MANY ISSUES STEMMING FROM HOT
NINETEEN THE BILL SIMPLY DOES
NOT ADDRESS THE NEEDED
CLARIFICATIONS RELATED TO
FAMILY FARMS. WE HAVE OFFERED
AMENDMENTS SB FIVE THIRTY NINE-
WELL WITHIN THE INTENT OF PROP
NINETEEN AND WE WILL COMMIT TO
WORKING WITH FEDERAL HERTZBERG
CHOIR AND THE OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AS THIS CONTINUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THE FARM BUREAU WE KNOW THIS IS
ALSO AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN THE
MAJORITY LEADERS AND WORKING
WITH SENATOR DOLLY ON THIS AS
WELL WHO IS BEING. ARE DIRECTLY
ENGAGED AS WELL. MISTER RICE
JERRY OKAY IF WE WAIT ON COM
UNTIL WE GET THROUGH THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'LL GO TO THE VICE
CHAIR TO BE A STARTER MEMBER
COMMENTS IN JUST A MOMENT.
LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COLLEGE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NOT A MODERATOR. AT
MY MADAM MY UNDERSTANDING IS
MEADOW MODERATOR THAT WE HAVE
OUR CO HOST WHO ARE NOW
AVAILABLE ON OUR- ARE EXCUSE
ME- TWO WITNESSES LEAD
WITNESSES MISTER TURNER BURKE
WHO IS THE ORANGE COUNTY
ASSESSOR. IS WELL AS OF NSF
ZERO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION REALTORS- I'M
WONDERING THAT A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE ADVANCED MISSILE
ZERO. AND ASSESSOR DURENBERGER
AT TWO AT THE LINE PLEASE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE. UHHUH UHHUH PLAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE REDUCE HAVING
OR TO LEAVE WITNESSES. IT
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND WE'LL
HEAR FROM IN THE MODERATOR HERE
SHORTLY ABOUT MR NUMBER AS WELL
AS NECESSARY. OKAY MISTER JOHN
NUMBER LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ERNEST ROXBURGH I AM THE
ASSESSOR RECORDER CLERK FOR
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO. I AM HERE
TODAY AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSORS
ASSOCIATION TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT
FOR AB FIVE THIRTY NOT.
EXAGGERATIONS PROP NINETEEN
PASSPORT IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
MEMBERS AND LEGAL STAFF HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON REQUIRED A
MEMBERS FOR PROP NINETEEN SINCE
THE END OF. NOVEMBER OF LAST
YEAR. A LARGE FOR OF THE BILL
AND TWENTY UNIT INCLUDES THE
LANGUAGE DEVELOPED BY THE TRASH.
THREE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S BELIEVE THAT AB FIVE
THIRTY NINE IS ADEQUATE THE
CURRENT YEAR EACH. DESPERATELY
NEEDED. FERVENTLY YOU TO FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO AND- WE
GET WE NEED TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
IS YOUR NUMBER TURNER TRULY IS
A PROPERTY TAX ALLEGING THE
CITY CALIFORNIA FORMER MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
INDUSTRY TASK WORK. IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND HAS THE
BEST BOW TIES EVERYBODY BUT WE
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO AYE
SISTER GONNA BURKE FOR HIS
MUCH SIR LET'S NOW GO TO OUR
SECOND LEAD WITNESS THAT
VANESSA- ZERO FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS. BETTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE Q. WE HAVE BENEFIT
CHABOT ON THE LINE. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE NATIONAL DENTAL CHáVEZ
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS AND
WE'RE PLEASED TO JOIN SENATOR
HERTZBERG IN SUPPORT OF THAT
FIVE THREE NINE. THREE SAID
LIKE TO BEGIN BY SENATOR. FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND BRINGING
COMPLETE MEASURE. AND WE WOULD
ALSO TO READ. AND BEING THE
COLOR AND STAFF BETTER TRY WORK
ON THE MEASURE. LAST YEAR WITH
MY BY. LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT
SEEING OUR ALLY WITH THAT
CALIFORNIA PERFECT FIRE. SIX CO
APA ELEVEN ALL KNOWN AS CARPET
NINETY WHICH ALLOWS LOG FIRED.
SENIOR AND SEVERELY DISABLED
AND DOES TO TRANSFER. THE TAX
BASIS OF THEIR RESIDENCE TO
REPLACE GLOW OF THE LAST VALUE.
I THINK THREE CLEAR I THINK
THIS LAW RELATED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION CAN AND-
NINETEEN. THEREBY ELIMINATING
AND IN THE MY PLACE AND PROVIDE
SENIOR CENTER QUALIFY HOME WITH
COMPANY TO GET A TO MAKE
IMPORTANT COULD BE DECISIONS.
IN PARTICULAR FIVE THREE NINE
CLEAR THE OP DATE OF THE CHANGE
IN. THAT COULD CONTAINED IN
NINETEEN BY MAKING THAT YOU THE-
OF THEIR RICH PROP OR THAT. OR
NEW KIND UP THERE BUT WORKPLACE
MENTAL. BUT NOT THE ME AND
PRIOR TO APRIL TWO TWENTY. WE
BELIEVE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
CLARIFY THE LINE ORDER TO PROP
NINETEEN IS IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE
THE METER CAL. AND ALSO I'M
FELT THAT IT MAY PROVIDE
DIGNITY TO QUALIFYING
HOMEOWNERS. IF I THREE NINE IF
THE CRITICAL KERR. MEASURES
WOULD BAN. ABOUT THE- YARD WITH
RESPECTFULLY WITH YOUR- SB FIVE
THREE NINE AND WE FORWARD TO
WORKING STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THE
WAY THANK YOUNG. MISS IS YOUR
CHáVEZ THINK SO MUCH WE PRE
YOUR TEST FROM ASSOCIATION
REALTORS. MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO DO A LOT CALL FOR THE
IN SUPPORT LET CALL. CALL FOR
THE INSTEAD. OF SB FIVE THIRTY
NOW THE WE'LL GO TO. MADAM LAST
CALL FOR SOME. THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THE TICKET.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
LINE FIFTEEN YEAR AND I'M READY.
HELLO A GOOD MORNING YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH
LINE FIFTEEN GO AHEAD. OKAY I'M
GOING TO REGISTER OPPOSITION SO
I'LL COME BACK AND THEN YOU CAN
FINISH THIS PORTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MANY
MODERATOR LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANYONE
WHO MAY BE IN THE QUEUE IN
SUPPORT IF NOT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION MOMENTARILY MADAME
MODERATOR. THERE ARE NO FOR THE
PARTICIPANTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MASON JENNA
COMMITTEE NOW WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE THIRTY NINE
WE HAVE THREE DIFFERENT WAYS
THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE.
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE IS WELL AS ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE SO LET'S START
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS WE HAVE NO
ONE WISHING TO OFFER OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY IN THE CHAMBERS. LAYS
IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE LONELIEST ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL ROOM ONE TWELVE IT'S
TAKE A LOOK AT ONE TWELVE.
ESPECIALLY LONELY ONTHIS
WEDNESDAY MORNING RIGHT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO OFFER UP TESTIMONY TODAY IN
OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE THIRTY NINE. PLEASE DIAL.
844-291-6364 THE ACCESS CODE
EIGHT SEVEN SIX. EIGHT NINE
FOUR ONE OF COURSE THAT IS ON
YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW IS WELL
LET'S GET THAT PHONE NUMBER UP
ON THE SCREEN IF WE COULD
PLEASE. OR MAYBE NOT. SO NOW
LET'S GO TO OUR PHONE LINES
MADAM MADAM OPERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE Q. THOSE WHO ARE
IN OPPOSITION THOSE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIVE THIRTY
NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTEEN PEOPLE
HAD. CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME. YES
SIR YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE WE
WELCOME YOU PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ERIC PAIN
I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY URBAN INSTITUTE-
IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA WILL BE
REPRESENT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF VOICES- RELATIVE TO LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. I
REALIZED WITH IMPLEMENTATION
THIS IS THE IMPLEMENTATION
LANGUAGE BUT I'M HOPEFUL THAT
THE LEGISLATOR WILL WE REVISIT
OPPOSITION NINETEEN YOUR OWN
CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY IS LAUNCHING THE BLACK
WEALTH INITIATIVE DURING BLACK
HISTORY MONTH. REPORTED THAT
FOR THE PAST DECADE CALIFORNIA
BLACK HOMEOWNERSHIP RATE HAS
BEEN LOWER THAN IT HAS BEEN IN
THE NINETEEN SIXTIES WHEN IT
WAS COMPLETELY LEGAL TO
DISCRIMINATE AGAINST BLACK HOME
BUYERS. AND THE TWO THOUSAND
AND 19401% OF BLACK FAMILIES
OWN THEIR HOMES WELL I THINK
THE 8% OF WHITE FAMILIES 56% A
DIFFERENT DIFFICULT HIGHLANDERS.
WERE HOME OWNERS- WE- LET ME
KNOW. OWN HOMES AT A RATE OF
14% WHICH IS ALSO. AFTER YEARS
OF THE- I MEAN DISCRIMINATION.
WITH BLACK HOMEOWNERS CAL. WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PALA THAT
BRING A- TO CLOSE THE WEALTH
GAP NOT MAKING IT WORSE.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY BIG
DEBTS THAT PROPOSITION NINETEEN
PROTECTION. FOR
INTERGENERATIONAL PROPERTY TAX
FOR. PROTECTION CAMPAIGN THEIR
PROPOSITION FIFTY EIGHT AND ONE
NINETY THREE THERE CAN BE
OPPORTUNITY TO MODIFY THE FOR
CRACK AND BUT THAT MODIFICATION
SHOULD BE DOWN WITH FULL AND
OPEN PUBLIC DEBATE. DEBATE
THOUGH SO MANY FAMILIES OF
COLOR BILL OF SOME MANY
FAMILIES. SO MANY FAMILIES OF
COLOR BILL BLINDSIDED BY
PROPOSITION NINETEEN AND WE ARE
LOOKING FOR ANSWERS AND FOR A
COLLISION. THAT MAKE THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. I'M
SORRY SIR GO AHEAD AND BURKE
WORKING YOUR TEST OF THIRD
SECONDS OR THIRTY THREE PLEASE
CONCLUDE. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING ON TO THOSE WHO
ARE ALSO IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION WE'RE GONNA
ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE DO
IN THE FINAL CALL FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN OPPOSITION. BETTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
QUEUE UP FINAL CALL FOR ALL
THOSE WHO WERE IN OPPOSITION.
GO AHEAD MODERATOR. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT THANK YOU. WE
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S PATIENCE
FOR GETTING OUR OPPOSITION WAY
TESTIMONY READY TO ROLL. THANK
YOU AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTEEN IF I HAD. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE
GOOD MORNING YEAH HE'S PRESSING.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JULIA
BADLY NINETEENTH WITH ON NEWS
THAT A FRESNO CALIFORNIA. HI
YOU HAVE THAT HAVE A GREAT
CONCERN THAT WITH THE PASSING
OF THE BILL THAT PUBLIC NOTICE
WAS NOT DONE PROPERLY WE CAN BE
ABLE TO NOTIFY OUR COMMUNITY-
WE SPECIFICALLY GO TO AFRICAN
AMERICANS. ALLEGED CALIFORNIA
AND BEING ON THE CALL WITH MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES TO. BE THERE
WAS NO INFORMATION THAT WAS PUT
OUT ABOUT. THE DEADLINE REPORTS
OR SIXTEEN THIS IS REALLY GONNA
BACK HOME OWNERSHIP FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ALREADY
LOOKING AT 41% IS FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND THAT NUMBER WILL.
INEVITABLY DROP AND SO WE ARE
CONCERNED AS MEDIA BLACK MEDIA
IN GENERAL THAT THE INFORMATION
IS NOT GOING OUT- IN ENOUGH
TIME SO THAT WE CAN
APPROPRIATELY GIVE PEOPLE THE
INFORMATION TO CHANGE UP. THE
PAPERWORK AND TO BE ABLE. THE
TO TRANCE POP INFO FORTH AND I
DO SO I THAT THE- AND HOW-
LEGISLATION HAS. TO CROSS THAT
AND THAT IT MIGHT. A
REPRESENTATIVE MEDIA. THANK YOU
FOR REALLY GREAT FOR THAT YOU
TAKE THE TIME TO BE A CALLER AN
OFFER OF YOUR CONCERNS THANK
YOU SO MUCH MA'AM. THAT MEANT A
MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. WE HAVE
NO OTHER COLLEGE THANK YOU. I
JUST OF AND TO BE CAUTIOUS
MATTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
DO ONE LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND THERE ARE NO COLLEGE
QUEUING UP THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK TODAY
MODERN MODERATOR WE'RE NOT
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE- IF IT IS THE WILL
COMMITTEE W'RE GONNA TURN IT
OVER TO THE VICE CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR. OF THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SALINAS OFF ON COMMITTEE
COMING MISTER VICE CHAIR GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'D LIKE TO INQUIRE OF
THE ADVOCATE FOR THE FARM GIRL
WHAT WAS A FARM BUREAUS
POSITION ON THIS. LAST YEAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. LET ME CHECK
IN WITH. PADDY WHO IS DOING AN
AMAZING JOB- DO WE STILL HAVE
THE FARM BUREAU ON THE LINE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR CAN YOU GIVE
US. SIXTY SECONDS OF COURSE I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO FRAME THE
SAME QUESTION TO THE REALTORS
THANK YOU SO MUCH GIVE US SIXTY
SECONDS. OKAY RIGHT AND WALDRON.
YEAH. ALL. MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE SO WHAT WE'D LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO DO IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH YOU- MISTER VICE CHAIR
WE'RE GOING TO ASK- THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE BRING
FORWARD MISLI CERRO CHAVEZ
MISUSE ZERO CHAVEZ FROM THE
REALTORS FIRST AND THEN WHAT WE
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ASK THE
MODERATOR TO DO IS TO ASK IF
THE FARM BUREAU REPRESENTATIVE
IS STILL ON THE LINE MATTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN ALSO ASK
IF THE FARM BUREAU
REPRESENTATIVE IS STILL ON THE
LINE. AS THE VICE CHAIR HAS A
QUESTION FOR HIM IF NOT-
SENATOR HERTZBERG WILL WORK
WITH SENATOR NIELSEN ON
CONNECTING THE FARM BUREAU
CENTER NIELSEN BUT FIRST LET'S
GO TO OUR REPRESENTATIVE ONE OF
OUR LEAD WITNESSES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS NOT A MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE BRING IN VANESSA
ZERO CHAVEZ FROM THE REALTORS.
THANK YOU BENEFIT LIQUOR
CABINET HAS OPENED MY- I THINK
YOU- MISTER CHAIR AND- TO
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS SENATOR
NIELSEN QUESTIONS JUST TO BE
CLEAR ARE YOU ASKING FOR- OUR
POSITION SPECIFICALLY WE ARE
LIKE A CO SPONSOR OF.
PROPOSITION NINETEEN AND IT IS-
MY RECOLLECTION THAT THE FARM
BUREAU BUT THE CORE OF THE
MEASURE HE WAS IN SUPPORT. WAS
OR WAS NOT. YES OKAY THE
CONCERN I HAVE LATE WHERE AM I
SAW THE PROOF THE PROVISIONS
LAST YEAR THEY WERE DETRIMENTAL
I FELT TO SUCCESSION OF
OWNERSHIP IN AGRICULTURE AND I
COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHY THE
FARM BUREAU WOULD SUPPORT THAT
BUT NO I I'M SORRY MISTER RIGHT
HERE THIS IS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SO IF YOU DON'T KNOW
I KNOW SHE WAS JUST. AND I
THOUGHT SIMILARLY THE THAT THAT
THAT WOULD BE OF CONCERN TO THE
REALTORS HI. I'M MISS IS YOUR
CHáVEZ ONE MORE TIME WOULD YOU
MIND STATING THAT CAL SO SHE OF
REALTORS. POSITION BOTH ON PROP
NINETEEN AND THEN ALSO ON. THE
BILL AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO THE FARM BUREAU MRS HERE
TRAVIS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
RESTATE YOUR- THAT THE
ASSOCIATION'S POSITION
CALIFORNIA SEARCHES FOR
REALTORS POSITION. ON PROP
NINETEEN AND WHY YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT AND THEN ALSO ON SB
FIVE THIRTY NINE THIS IS THE
SERRA CHáVEZ PLEASE PROCEED.
THIRTY A. R. WITH A CO SPONSOR
OF PROPOSITION NINETEEN
ALTERNATE NAGY CA ELEVEN- AND
WE BELIEVE THAT IT ALLOWED PER-
YOU HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
MOVE THROUGHOUT. I THOUGHT
CONFIDING FOR INTERGENDER.
TRANSFER AND REMOVING THE
ABUSES CURRENTLY ACCEPTED
BLOCKED. THANK YOU MISTER HERE
CHAVEZ- ONE MORE TIME AND YOU
IN SUPPORT AND SB FIVE THIRTY
NINE CORRECT. THAT IS CORRECT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MISTER VICE
CHAIR DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE REALTORS FOR
WE GO TO THE FARM BUREAU NO ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR
DID PLEASE MAKE A REQUEST TO
THOSE WHO ARE LISTENING IF WE
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU NOT A
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
THEM UP NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU
ADD THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU.
ONE ZERO AT THE TIME. ONE
PLEASE THANK YOU. AND MINE
TWELVE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING I WANNA YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU JUST A
PLEASE RESET YOUR FIRST. VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN IS- IT IS IT WHAT
IS THE FARM BUREAU'S POSITION
ON THIS BILL AND IF YOU ARE NOT
IN SUPPORT CAN YOU PLEASE STATE
WHY- PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
AGAIN ROBERT SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION. TO THE
TO THE QUESTION POSED BY MR
HILTON AND THE VICE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE THE FARM BUREAU
IS COMMITTED ON SB FIVE THIRTY
NINE SIMPLY BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS A LANGUAGE THAT
IS FURTHER EEDED TO CLARIFY
THE PROVISIONS IMPROPER
NINETEEN. ARMS AS AN
ORGANIZATION SERVICE YOU KNOW-
THE POSITION THAT WE TOOK ON
PROP NINETEEN OF STATIC IS.
DICTATED TO US BY OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. ON PROPOSITION
NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WAS NEUTRAL
ON THAT. PARTICULAR PROVISION-
IN THAT OVER ON THE NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY BALLOTS ARE.
MISTER VICE CHAIR WE'RE GONNA
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO YOU IF
YOU HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS OF
MR SPIEGEL IN VIEW DON'T MIND
MISTER VICE YOUR KEYS FOR YOUR
MIGHT CLOSE YOUR MOUTH I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT BUT AND
IT'S A VICE CHAIR THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. FOR MR SPIEGEL MISTAKE
OF THE FARM BUREAU THEN ON PROP
NINETEEN WAS NEUTRAL TECHNO
PHYSICIAN. THAT IS CORRECT
MISTER NELSON AND WHY WOULD YOU
TAKE NO POSITION I STILL VIEW
THAT AS HARMFUL TO AGRICULTURAL
SUCCESSION. IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION AND IT WAS ONE THAT
WAS ONE I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT DECISIONS OF OUR
ORGANIZATION OF THE BOARD. THE
GOOD AND THE BAD ASSOCIATED THE
INITIATIVE REQUIRED AND
EXAMINATION OF THE PORTABILITY
AND RECIPROCITY PROVISIONS OF
OTHER REAL PROPERTY SWITCH- ARE
DEFINITELY TAX BENEFITS TOO
MANY FAMILY FARMERS AND
FAMILIES BUT AT THE SAME TIME.
THE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
FAMILY FARM FOR A BIT
CONFUSING- TO REALLY SPEAK TO
THAT. THE DISCUSSION AT THE
BOARD WAS THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME BENEFIT PROVIDED TO FAMILY
FARMERS AS WELL WHAT THE INTENT
WAS BEHIND PROP NINETEEN. THE
INTENTION BEHIND PROP TEAM PROP
NINETEEN AS RELATED TO FAMILY
FARMS WAS TO ALLOW THE NEXT
GENERATION OF FAMILY FARMERS TO
CONTINUE IN OPERATION WITHOUT%
BEING FINANCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
THAT WAS THE INTENT THAT'S WHAT
WE SHARED TO MY ORGANIZATION
AND TO THE FARMING AND RANCHING
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. GIVEN THAT INFORMATION
IS PROVIDED TO OUR BOARD OUR
MEMBERSHIP WE FELT THAT THE
FARMING COMMUNITY AND- THE
GREATER AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
CALIFORNIA WOULD BE PROTECTED-
THAT HAS BEEN OUR UNDERSTANDING
IN THE INITIATIVE. UNTIL WE
STARTED BEING THE INFORMATION
FROM THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
ASSEMBLY WHAT THE GUIDANCE
PROVIDED IN THE L. D. A IS THAT
THE LETTER WAS ACTORS. THAT
DEFINITELY- RAISED SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS I HOPE THAT I HOPE
THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION SIR.
YES IT DOES TO ME IT WAS VERY
CLEAR THAT THIS WOULD BE VERY
DETRIMENTAL TO SUCCESSOR SHIP.
AND THE FARMS DON'T NORMALLY
JUST PASSED FROM ONE PARENT TO
A CHILD EITHER GENERALLY OR
MORE MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY. AND
A THIRD OF THE DIFFICULTY WAS A
TRICKLE THE REQUIREMENT OF
RESIDENCY- IN THE IN THE IN THE
IN THE HALL. WAS THAT NOT PART
OF THE ISSUE. BAKULA AND TO-
CITADEL HURTS CREDIT AND TO
MISTER. CREDIT THERE WAS. THIS
PROVISIONS TO THAT ISSUE
INCLUDED AN ATHLETE FIVE
THIRTY. WHICH STATE SPECIFIC
THAT THE FAMILY FARM NEED NOT
ALSO BE BE PERSONAL RESIDENCE-
OF THE TRANSFER TRANSFEREE
THERE IS INTENDED TO BE WITHIN
PROP NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BUT
BENEFIT IF YOU WILL TO THE
FAMILY FARM IN THAT THE HOME
AND RESIDENTS TO BE EXCLUDED
FROM THE FAMILY FARM PROPERTY
ITSELF. WOULD BE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF NECESSARILY BOTH-
YOU TEST PROVISIONS ONE FOR A
PERSONAL RESIDENCE AND ONE FOR
THE FAMILY FARM. THE I DO OF.
THE CHAIRS AND THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S INTEREST IN TRYING TO.
SQUARE THIS UP THE THOUGHT
THAT'S ALL I HAVE BETTER MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS RIGHT SURE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AS YOU JENNA
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE TURN IT
BACK TO SENATOR HERTZBERG FOR
CLOSE WE'D LIKE TO BE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FINAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WERE DOING A LAST CALL
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HEARING SEEN
NINE MR MAJORITY LEADER FLOOR'S
YOURS VEHICLES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMENTS IN THE QUESTIONS AND
OUR EFFORTS TO CLARIFY I MEAN
LOOK OFTEN WHEN CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS AS I SAID IN MY
OPENING ARE DRAFTED TO A WE
NEED STATUTORY LANGUAGE CLARIFY
THAT WE'RE GIVING EMERGENCY
REGULATORY POWER TO THE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION. I WAS HAPPY TO
HEAR THAT MR JOINER BURKE
REPRESENTING THE ASSESSORS- THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STATE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION SUPPORT ARM OF
THIS MEASURE THE- FIREFIGHTERS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE THE
VILLAGERS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AN EFFORT TO CLEAN UP
THEY'RE STILL I SUSPECT IS I
HOPE AS I SAID IN MY OPENING. A
FEW OTHER ISSUES THE POINT
ABOUT TIME IS CERTAINLY BEING
TAKEN IN CONSIDERATION WITH
RESPECT TO CREATING THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE CAN WITHIN
THE CONSTITUTIONAL CONSTRAINTS
THAT OF THE VOTERS THAT WE'RE
DOING HERE AND SO I AND I JUST
WANT TO STRESS THAT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE MOVING AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN- IN IN IN INTEREST TO TRY
TO DEAL WITH ANY UNCERTAINTY
THIS MEASURE WAS EXPEDITED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE EXPEDITED
AS UPSET. AS A SINGLE SUBJECT
HEARING TODAY. IT'S JUST TAX
LAW BUILD MINUTES A- IT JUST
MEANS THAT WHEN IT PASSES BOTH
HOUSES. AND SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR GOES INTO EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY WHICH IS THE ISSUE
AT HAND SO THAT WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE PRACTICAL. REALITIES
OF IMPLEMENTATION WITH THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION ON THIS
AND AGAIN WILL CONTINUE THAT
DISCUSSION WITH THE FARM BUREAU
AND FOR THAT I ASTRONOMICAL
THANK YOU SO KINDLY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS THE MAJORITY LEADER
MR MAJORITY LEADERS
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE IS THERE A MOTION TO
APPROVE. YES WE HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR REID SO THE MOTION
IS A DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MR NOW PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. MCGUIRE AYE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DO ALSO. TWO HOURS AGO
HI SENATOR HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO JENNA
COMMITTEE THAT'S A FIVE ZERO
VOTE WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE
VOTE THAT MOTION PASSES AS IN
GENERAL COMMITTEE THAT IS OUR-
ARE MEETING FOR TODAY ARE
HEARING FOR TODAY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE ALL FOR WITNESSES
WHO PARTICIPATED THANK YOU ALL.
FOR YOUR PATIENCE WE WANT TO
THANK ALL THE FOLKS WHO ARE
BEHIND THE SCENES MAKING THIS A
COMMITTEE WORK EACH AND EVERY
DAY HE IS WELL WE'LL BE BACK
WITH YOU FOR OUR NEXT HEARING
NEXT WEEK FACING GERMAN THIS
FIRST HEARING. OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IT'S OUR JUNE.